well and NZ by a Hollywood card tester I
know Dyson / says most people think of
movie stars when they think of Hollywood
but there's also a tiny village of that
name population barely a hundred in
Ireland he's here to test the new Opel
Insignia the typical company car most
drivers want their office on wheels to
get from A to B quickly quietly smoothly
and economically so he's going to see
how well the insignia powered by the
whisper diesel can do just that come
show me on set stock opals product
offensive is moving ahead full speed
that includes a thorough upgrade of the
range of diesel engines the market debut
of the 2.0 cdti ushered in a new
generation of diesels and three power
outputs for Opel models from the Corsa
to the insignia the 2-liter diesel in
the insignia we testin is touted as
quieter cleaner and more fuel-efficient
the new leader of the diesel pack posts
125 kilowatts of power and 400 Newton
metres of torque adding up to four
percent more performance and fourteen
percent more torque than its predecessor
opals alpha wolf leaps from 0 to 100
km/h and 9.4 seconds reaching a top
speed of 220 km/h the car maker rates
fuel consumption as 4.7 litres per 100
kilometers
I sequence and NZ I know points out that
eighty percent of Germany's insignia
buyers choose a station wagon an
eighty-five percent one a diesel engine
the introduction of the whisper diesel
will probably increase this number from
inside the car the 170 horsepower engine
is as quiet as a gasoline-powered one
and just a sensitive in responding to
the pedal HMI stands for human machine
interface a networked front cabin
through which the driver communicates
with the car that includes the steering
wheel control interface the center
consoles touchscreen speech recognition
and the instrument cluster in front of
the driver all designed to minimize
distractions in traffic the 2-liter cdti
uses the blue injection scr system to
remove nitrogen oxide from its emissions
much as trucks do a smidgen of add blue
a mixture of urea and distilled water is
injected into the exhaust the resulting
ammonia breaks the nitrogen oxide down
into harmless nitrogen and steam
the arrested easily move I know
concludes that the whispered diesel is a
whole new generation it has more power
and accelerates better than its
predecessor and it produces less
vibration it could be a tad sporty-er
but the insignia is a bit too porky for
that if it were lighter it would be
nimble here when he carries weight